y llegó el momento de hablar de salud de
nuestro espacio directo américa ya está
lista en el estudio más romeros a la mar
bienvenida ya estamos a mitad de semana
vamos a hablar de una muy buena noticia
además creo que es esperanzadora más
reportaron la primera mujer curada de
vih en el mundo le pregunta entonces
cómo sucedió todo esto pues sí buenos
días raúl realmente nos gusta poder
traer este tipo de noticias que pues
empiezan a indicar que puede haber una
esperanza no al menos así sea a largo
plazo se trata de una paciente de eeuu
que también sufría de leucemia sabemos
que es un tipo de cáncer recibió un
trasplante de células madre pueda para
curar este tipo de cáncer y luego pues
después de este trasplante ya lleva 14
meses sin poder detectar el vih en su
cuerpo a pesar de que ha dejado de usar
tratamiento antirretroviral es del
tercer caso en todo el mundo pero se
trata de la primera mujer entonces para
entender los detalles y también las
implicaciones de esta noticia estamos
con el doctor oscar franco profesor de
la universidad de berna de epidemiología
y de salud pública doctor
buenos días gracias por estar con
nosotros explíquenos en qué consiste
este tratamiento de transplantes de
células madre
si la mujer recibió un tratamiento que
se llamado terapia regenerativa y en
concreto lo que se hizo fue un
trasplante de células madre procedentes
del cordón umbilical de un donante que
tenía o que tiene resistencia natural al
vih y esto se suplementó con unas
células adultas donadas por un familiar
para facilitar cómo actuar como puente
para que las otras células poderes
pudieran generar un buen sistema inmune
o una buena defensa de esta paciente
tenía leucemia y por eso se dio este
tratamiento se buscaba tratar la
leucemia o curar la leucemia pero
también curar el vih ya estaban 14 meses
en lo que podría parecerse una cura que
se llama cura funcional porque sabemos
que el vih puede durar durante mucho
tiempo y aparecen años después doctor
también hablamos muchísimo de las
famosas células madres pero le pregunta
entonces una pregunta muy simple pero
que a lo mejor muchos no sabemos
realmente qué son que son estas células
madre
las células madres son las únicas
células del organismo que se pueden
dividir y generar otro tipo de células
que se pueden especializar entonces se
pueden diferenciar entre células por
ejemplo el tejido óseo células
sanguíneas o células cerebrales o puedes
crear otras células madre como en un
proceso que sean auto renovación
entonces estas células madre son como la
materia prima del cuerpo y se podrían
utilizar para reparar tejidos y para
curar muchísimas enfermedades sin
embargo también se han utilizado
muchísimo por algunas clínicas de muy
buena reputación que tratan de vender
terapias de células madre y que
realmente pues no son serias hoy y que
hay que tener mucha vigilancia en lo que
se está haciendo con estas células
doctor estaba hablando de una inmunidad
natural de personas que tienen inmunidad
natural contra el virus del vih en qué
consiste esta inmunidad sabemos que se
trata de una mutación de un gen cómo
funciona y es realmente común que exista
esta mutación en la población mundial
si se encuentra una mutación
básicamente es una multiplicación que se
+ ccr5 que se encuentra más o menos en
un 1% de descendientes europeos del
norte y esto se encontró y ayudó
muchísimo para poder entender el
mecanismo de cómo se pega el virus y
resulta que los pacientes que tienen
esta mutación el receptor donde se pega
el virus no funciona lo suficientemente
bien entonces son resistentes al vih y
este entender este proceso entender la
existencia de esta mutación nos puede
ayudar a generar nuevas formas de
tratamiento y nuevas formas de entender
la enfermedad ahora doctor también le
pregunto de la importancia que tiene
este caso que sea de de curación que se
haya producido en una mujer
si es la primera mujer ya teníamos otros
dos casos el primer caso fue en 2008 que
se llamó el caso del paciente berlín
segundo caso fue el caso de londres y
este es el caso de una mujer en nueva
york que es una mujer de edad media no
sé no sé de hecho la edad no es
exactamente el nombre para mantener el
anonimato y que tiene una raza mixta
entonces es la primera mujer la primera
mujer con esta con este tipo de raza
mixta y por eso es tan importante
y vamos a ver si esto puede ayudar para
ofrecer a tratamientos más personas que
puedan crecer para beneficiar y sobre
todo también porque es importante al
final que estos estudios estos
tratamientos también adelante pues cómo
funciona el vih y esas posibles curas en
las mujeres la mayor parte de los
estudios siguen dándose en hombres
entonces pues es una buena noticia
también que tengamos esta información
quería preguntarle también alrededor de
este trasplante sabemos que es un método
bastante agresivo es un caso puntual
este que ha sucedido ahora o es posible
que se extienda a otros pacientes con
vih
por ahora es una terapia que pues no
solamente puede tener muchos riesgos
sino que además tiene mucho costo y
requiere unas una tecnología hay un
sistema de servicio que sea muy de alta
capacidad entonces no se puede ofrecer a
mucha gente se estima que más o menos a
máximo 50 pacientes se le podría ofrecer
al año en eeuu estamos hablando de
millones 38 millones más o menos de
personas que tienen el vih en el mundo
lo que sí promete es entender por
ejemplo la mutación que hablábamos
podría ayudar a generar una terapia
genética que en un futuro quizás se
puede se pudiera distribuir a través del
mundo con una inyección o de otra forma
y esto podría ayudar también a
desarrollar medicamentos que podrían
actuar como actuar la mutación bloquear
los receptores que utiliza el virus para
para invadir el organismo pues doctor
gracias entonces por toda la información
gracias a mara también por la
información y por tocar este tema tan
importante pues que abre la puerta a
pues una de las tantas curas que están
desarrollándose en contra esta
enfermedad hablamos del vih/sida gracias
doctor gracias más nosotros ahora
saludamos
según diputado el día